hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast pre-clinical t-cell
immunotherapy strategies for overcoming
immunosuppression and solid tumors
presented by dr. Kristen Anderson from
the University of Washington for
Hutchinson Cancer Research Center
I am kale Ibaka blabbers and I will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by laberd's and sponsored by thermo
Fisher Scientific for more information
on our sponsor please visit thermo
Fisher com now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question and click on the
send button will answer as many
questions as views time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing this
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide wait if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I'd like to now introduce
our presenter dr. Kristin Anderson duct
er Anderson is a senior postdoctoral
researcher at the University of
Washington and the Fred Hutchinson
Cancer Research Center in Seattle her
research investigates strategies for
treating solid tumors with adoptive
t-cell therapy currently she is
developing molecular engineering
strategies to improve tumour eradication
using genetically engineered cells in
ovarian cancer with the ultimate goal of
translating her findings into treatment
protocols for patients for a full bio
please see the speaker biography tab at
the
with your screen dr. Anderson you may
now begin your presentation hi everyone
thank you again so much for being here
today I'm really excited to talk to you
about some of our most recent work
basically engineering T cells to try to
kill solid tumors so as the introduction
stated my name is Kristen and I'm a
postdoc in Phil Greenberg's lab at the
Fred Hutchinson Cancer Research Center
in Seattle Washington and I'm affiliated
with the immunology department at the
University of Washington and so we
actually get to do some really cool
immunology and immunotherapy in this
setting because we've got an immense
amount of experience out here so when I
joined Phil's lab one of the projects
that he asked me to start working on was
to take this idea that t-cells have this
ability to kill cancer and that we can
engineer them to be even better at it
and try to make it work in solid tumors
because his lab had had a lot of success
making this an effective anti tumor
therapy in leukemias and we really
wanted to push this to make it something
that we could take to the clinic in
solid tumors as well so before I jump
into the data I just want to confirm for
everyone that I have no financial
disclosures to make no relationships to
disclose and the goals of our session
today the things I'm going to be
focusing on have a lot to do with
considering preclinical models and how
what we're studying is related to what's
going on in human disease so I'm going
to talk a little bit about the
immunocompetent mouse model that we've
been working in or ovarian cancer and
talk about how we're trying to use both
analysis of human tissue samples as well
as these Mouse samples in order to
better understand what kinds of
immunosuppressive features there are in
human tumors and how the mouse can
recapitulate some of those features and
how we can actually use that to our
advantage so the two examples I'm going
to talk about today our strategies where
we used whole transcriptome Biosystems
in order to understand what similarities
actually do exist between the mouse
model we chose and
human disease and then validating all of
that using immunohistochemistry in
addition to that I'm also going to talk
a little bit about ways that once we
know what suppressive obstacles are in
front of us we can try to engineer or
use combination strategies in order to
overcome some of those obstacles in the
micro environment and then finally I'll
give you one example of something we've
been working on really recently that
we're very excited about one way that we
have found can actually overcome some of
those hurdles some of those death
signals in both ovarian and pancreatic
cancer that we're getting some really
exciting data about so I want to go back
and talk a little bit about why we
actually started working on ovarian
cancer when I joined Phil's lab one of
the big hurdles in t-cell therapy and
immunotherapy in general was that there
was a lot of evidence that things like
checkpoint blockade and engineered T
cells were really effective against
things like leukemia and check my
blockade was starting to show a lot of
real exciting promise in a lot of
different kinds of solid tumors
especially things like melanoma but
there were still some tumors that no
matter how hard we tried didn't really
show a lot of change and so ovarian
cancer is one of those and ovarian
cancer is an incredibly devastating
disease because this is one where the
vast majority of patients who are
diagnosed are actually diagnosed at a
really really late stage of disease
because the symptoms of ovarian cancer
are quite nondescript we're talking
about things like feeling bloated or
needing to urinate frequently or feeling
really full even though you may not have
had a big meal things like that could be
associated with lots of different
medical issues and so an ovarian cancer
is not necessarily an assumption that
someone would make right away and so
oftentimes if someone has these symptoms
they don't go in to the doctor right
away or if they do it's not necessarily
the first test that's done so
unfortunately a lot of these patients
are diagnosed very late and when it's
diagnosed very late there's a fairly
poor prognosis for those patients so as
you can see from the data on the screen
the later the stage of diagnosis the
lower the 5-year anticipated survival
rates or outcome for those particular
patient
so what we thought we could do was to
take an image of some of the really
advanced engineering strategies that
were out there in the field and to try
to engineer t-cells to target antigens
that were already present in these
tumors to see if we could take someone's
immune system and make it stronger to
make it better against ovarian cancer so
adoptive t-cell therapy is actually
already in use in the clinic in several
different formats so for example tilt
therapy is the kind of therapy where we
isolate tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
from someone's tumor expand them in the
lab and then re-infuse them into the
patient or you may know quite a bit
about car t-cell therapy so t-cells that
are engineered to have a chimeric
antigen receptor which uses the SCF v or
antibody binding option of anybody with
t cell signaling molecules to help a
t-cell more effectively targets tumor
cells but in our strategy we're actually
one of two today
we actually are engineering t-cells to
have high affinity t-cell receptors and
one of the major reasons we focused on
this strategy was because there are a
good number of tumor antigens that are
not expressed on the tumor cell surface
and that can be problematic because
chimeric antigen receptors are excellent
tools for targeting tumor cells that
have a protein abundantly expressed on
the cell surface but at the moment
they're not great for targeting tumor
cells that express tumor antigens
intracellularly and some of the antigens
that we've chosen to target are things
like transcription factors or in the
case of the antigen I'm going to talk to
you about today they're proteins that
are frequently shed from the tumor cell
surface but the tumor cell can still be
detected as a tumor cell by a t cell
with the T cell receptor because that
antigen is still made as protein and
then processed and presented on peptide
MHC so a T cell with a high affinity T
cell receptor still has the potential to
see and eradicate those tumor cells even
if the antigen itself is shed from the
cell surface as a protein so the antigen
I talked to you about today is one
called Niza Filan and this
is one that we're really excited about
because an NCI working group actually
characterized this particular antigen as
one that would be a really great target
for a lot of different kinds of tumors
so our group Tom Schmidt and ingen Strom
this in the lab actually engineered
t-cells to have high affinity t-cell
receptors that targeted to different
epitopes of mesothelioma and so I'm
showing you tetra mer staining this is
basically flow cytometry where we stain
these cells with a tetra mer that is
essentially peptide MHC and in this case
these t-cell receptors recognize HLA a2
and then either the muse of the on 20 or
the musical and five-thirty epitope and
so we can make these cells we can make
lots of them that express this t-cell
receptor and can recognize that
appropriate antigen and if we co culture
those T cells with an ovarian cancer
cell line for example in this case I'm
showing you co culture with okar 3 which
is one tumor cell line that's been
identified as being like high-grade
serous ovarian cancer we see that these
T cells can actually induce cleave
caspase-3 in the targets and cleave
caspase-3 is a nice readout of induction
of cell death because it's one of the
last caspases in the a pop tonic pathway
so generally speaking once it's cleaved
the vast majority of those cells are on
their way to dying so this is really
exciting because we think we've got
something that we can move forward with
into the clinic but we know that solid
tumors present a vast array of obstacles
to t-cells of any kind even ones that
have been engineered and so our big
question was alright we've made these
cells but is it even possible that
they'll do anything because of all of
those immunosuppressive obstacles
they're up against so we hypothesized
that indeed we made these high affinity
t-cells and we think they can actually
slow to more growth and prolong survival
but we needed an immuno competent system
in order to test that out and the other
thing we wanted to look for was whether
there was any off tumor on target
toxicity because musa feel and is
technically a self protein and we wanted
to make sure that we weren't seeing any
immuno toxicities in healthy tissues due
to the t cells killing healthy cell
accidentally so we turned to this model
called the id8 veg F model so the way
that this was generated many years ago
was the group scraped epithelial cells
off the surface of a v6 mouse ovary and
grew them in culture until they
transformed into a cancer cell line and
so then in order to make this line even
more like high-grade serous ovarian
cancer another group transduced it to
overexpress vascular endothelial growth
factor or veg F and so that's the line
I'm going to talk to you about today so
what we do is we take this line and we
implant it into peritoneal e and we let
those tumors grow for six eight 10 weeks
and what ultimately happens is these
cells form nodules or tumors all
throughout the peritoneal cavity of the
animal and they vastly resemble
high-grade serous ovarian cancer that's
already in a metastatic stage so as you
can see from the images on the screen
when we screen these mice using an
ultrasound we can find these tumor
nodules throughout the cavity and
they're circled and highlighted by
arrows as well as we can find ascites
so in these mice they will eventually
develop terminal hemorrhagic ascites and
hemorrhagic ascites is actually a key
characteristic feature of a lot of
patients with high-grade serous ovarian
cancer so on the surface this line seems
to recapitulate a lot of the major
features of advanced stage metastatic
ovarian cancer now because we're gonna
target music Filan we want to make sure
that the mouse model accurately and
nicely expresses music feeling in order
to even see if we can do these
experiments so we performed
immunohistochemistry staining for music
Nealon so you can see a sample of human
high-grade serous tumor on the left so
the brown staining is music kneeling and
the mouse sample is on the right and we
went even further to double-check and
make sure that the level of expression
in the tumors was much higher than
healthy tissue so we took tissues from
either a healthy b6 mouse or a muse a
feeling knockout mouse or our ID at
tumors after they have been growing in
mice and we stained we did a Western
blot for me
vielen and as you can see from the blot
on the bottom of the screen the three
different tumor samples that we took all
had much higher expression of Nizza
feeling in the tumor then either the
lung music the allele lining of the lung
or the lining of the ovary so this was
encouraging because this suggested to us
again that this was actually a safe
thing to target so in order to engineer
ourselves we follow a strategy that's
similar to what is used to engineer
human cells for treatment in the clinic
so in this case we're going to use mouse
t-cells
and in our experiments we use the p14
strain of transgenic mouse so this is a
mouse that has been engineered so that
all of the cd8 t-cells have a t-cell
receptor or an epitope of LC mV this
virus this Mouse virus and all of these
cells also are expressing a congenic
marker so that when we engineer cells
and put them in an animal or even if we
just engineer cells and they're looking
at them in the dish we can find them
because we can stain for this protein
that's on the surface of the T cells so
we isolate splenocytes from the mice the
donor mice we activate the T cells in
vitro so we combine the cells with anti
cd3 and anti cd28 antibodies and we give
il-2 to the culture that way that
supports T cell growth and then we
actually will transduce two times on the
next two days with retrovirus containing
whatever constructs we want to put in in
this case our T cell receptor and then
we usually get transduction efficiencies
anywhere between 50 and 85 percent after
those first few steps but if we want to
enrich and increase the number of T
cells that we have expressing our
construct we can actually do one more
step where we irradiate some donors
splenocytes and pulse them with our
peptide of interest in this case Musa
Thielen and that we can co-culture our
transduced cells with those peptide
pulses monocytes
and expand the number that we have that
are appropriately transduced with the
construct we care about so then we can
do in-vitro experiments and really test
what these cells are able to do so the
first question that I had was whether or
not these engineered T cells could even
kill this ID 8 veggie cell line
and fortunately we were lucky and very
excited to see that they could so here
I'm showing Cleve caspase-3 staining
like I mentioned before so Cleve
caspase-3 expression in these I da veg F
cells after they've either been Co
cultured with musical and T cells which
you can see in red or ot one T cells so
these are P 14 T cells that we
engineered to express the ot1 t-cell
receptor which is a t-cell receptor
specific for ovalbumin chicken protein
so these are irrelevant cells they
shouldn't cause death in our target cell
line and we were happy to see that they
did not so we can quantitate this and
see that it's significantly greater in
Cleve caspase-3 is significantly greater
in the target cells after we've Co
cultured them with antigen specific T
cells and we also went one step further
and we utilized this technology called
the excelence instrument and this is an
instrument where you plate your target
cells and they adhere to the bottom of
the well and this plate actually has
electrodes and sends an electrical
signal along the bottom of the well so
anytime your target cells adhere it
impedes that electrical signal and the
computer can read that out and then when
you add your targets and your targets
induce death
excuse me your effector cells when they
induce death of your targets your
targets no longer adhere and so they no
longer impede that electrical signal and
that can be read out as an indirect
reading of target cell death so we did
that as well and found that we can
actually get even cleaner data when we
go down to lower EDT ratios so we
confirmed in multiple assays that yes in
fact our T cells that we engineer can
kill this particular tumor cell line so
moving forward we wanted to do some in
vivo experiments where we looked at
whether or not the T cells that we
engineered could get into tumors could
cause death in these tumors and could
ultimately prolong survival of these
mice so the timeline for these
experiments is much longer than what
many people are using when they do in
vivo assays so this model because it
takes so long to develop and because our
goal is ultimately to model advanced
stage metastatic disease
we actually inject these id8 cells into
the animals and then wait at least six
or seven weeks before we even start
screening to see if the tumors are there
and usually we don't start treatment
until anywhere between six to eight
weeks after tumor cell injection so
we're waiting until we can see those
nodules by ultrasound and so our goal
here is not to necessarily clear tumor
it's simply to make sure that we set the
bar high because we want to really mimic
as much as possible what kinds of
patients we would be when we first go
into the clinic in the clinical trial so
as soon as we found mice that have
measurable or detectable disease we
transfer t-cells intravenously and then
we give those T cells il-2 so we give
aisle two injections subcutaneously for
about ten days in order to support T
cell survival and proliferation so this
first experiment I'm going to show you
we just did one injection of T cells and
we took the mice down at various time
points to simply ask the question are
these cells even able to get into these
tumors because we know that a lot of
solid tumors have physical barriers that
prevent T cell infiltration so in this
case we were excited to see that yes in
fact we do see T cell infiltration so
this is immunohistochemical staining for
C 3 and as you can see in the very first
panel
if we don't transfer any T cells these
tumors have very very very few T cells
in them whatsoever after we transfer T
cells we see an influx of T cells in the
tumor and if we pull these out and we
actually do staining by flow cytometry
anywhere from 50 to 90 percent of these
cells are our donor T cells so most of
them are cd8 we don't seem to see an
influx in T regs so most of them are cd8
sand most of them are in fact our donor
cells but we've noticed as we let them
mice go and we watch these T cells over
time that they don't seem to be
persisting and this is not necessarily a
big surprise we are making our T cells
into effector T cells and the literature
has very elegantly shown that T cells
expand in the effector phase and then
contract after antigen is cleared or
after as they approach memory so as they
come out of that if
factor phase we would expect that cell
numbers would go down but unfortunately
we were seeing numbers very similar to
what they looked like
with no t-cell transfer at all so this
was concerning and I will actually come
back to this at the end of the talk to
talk about an obstacle that we wanted to
overcome in these tumors so our other
question was well the t-cells that are
still present at these later time points
what do they look like when we did
phenotyping and functional analysis to
see what these t-cells look like before
we put them into the mice they all have
an activated effect your phenotype much
like you'd expect
they have expression of C 69 and 400mb B
because they have recently seen antigen
in the dish in vitro but they also have
slight up regulation of a lot of the
molecules that we commonly consider to
be inhibitory receptors eighty-one
lagg-3 Tim 3-digit and so we put these
cells in we take them out and see how
the phenotype has changed so when we
pull these out at an early time point we
see that they still look activated and
when we pull them out at a late time
point this was the time point we were
most interested in we see that all of
these markers are still highly expressed
on the t-cells the donor t-cells that we
pull out of the tumor relative to the
donor cells we pull out of the spleen
and that was important to us because
that suggested that these cells it's
consistent with them having a signature
of being dysfunctional or
immunosuppressed so we wanted to see if
functionally the cells could actually
make anti tumour cytokines and so when
we make these cells in vitro screen
before we put them in they're very
capable of making interferon gamma and
TNF alpha but when we pull them out of
tumors at day 21 it's very clear that
they have vastly down a lost disability
and make cytokines so consistent with
the phenotype see it seems like these
t-cells are definitely becoming
dysfunctional and we know from vast
amounts of really awesome literature
that there are many many many ways that
the tumor microenvironment can cause T
cells to become dysfunctional and
there's so many I don't have time to get
into all of them today there are some
really awesome reviews out there that
you can read if you'd like to learn more
about driving to cell
function in the micro environment but we
knew that all of these were
possibilities any one of these or any
combination of these could be the reason
that our T cells are not retaining
function and and not persisting in the
tumor microenvironment so we wanted to
ask which features of this mouse model
we were using were similar to the
features that were present in human
ovarian cancer that way we could better
understand which obstacles we could
actually study in the Mouse disease so
we wanted to understand how much these
tumors in the id8 veg f Mouse model
actually recapitulated features of human
disease and to do this we use thermal
fissures applied Biosystems deep
transcriptome profiling in order to
truly understand what genes are being
overexpressed and what pathways are the
same or different between our
preclinical model and real patient
disease so to do this we got Mouse
samples from our tumor bearing mice at
late stages of disease and we were able
to get from a local repository some
samples of human disease from patients
and these samples that we obtained were
matched samples so we have samples from
five patients we have their primary
tumor we also have a sample of
metastatic disease from the same person
and we also have a matched normal tissue
sample or adjacent normal from the same
person that way we can really start to
ask questions about does the mouse model
look more like primary disease does it
look more like metastatic disease and
having samples from the same matched
patient actually makes the analysis nice
and clean so we got samples that were
fresh frozen yet surgery so either at
Mouse euthanasia and necropsy or in the
clinic when the patient was undergoing
debulking surgery we did RNA extraction
on all of these samples ourselves and
did quality testing to see what the
quality level was and in the vast
majority of cases we had really good
quality RNA but there were a few samples
that came back with slightly lower Rin
values and so when we sent our samples
to the thermal Fisher team they actually
were able to do quality
control and checks on their end and told
us that even though the Rinne values and
the quality was a little lower that they
thought the asset would still
potentially work and we were fortunate
that it did so we sent our samples to
the services labs and they performed the
applied Biosystems microarray for us and
what was really nice about this we had
them do the clarium deep eco assay and
we chose the Pico assay because we knew
that some of the RNA samples we had from
our particular tissues we're quite
limited in quantity and so we wanted to
do something that was incredibly good at
low low levels of input and then Clary
MD is one of the more recent microarray
designs and what's really nice about
this one is that the probes actually
cover and they have great coverage of
all the exons that you would care about
but they also cover splicing sites so
you can get a lot of information about
different splice of isoforms an
expression of non-coding RNAs as well so
then for software analysis we utilized
both the transcriptome analysis console
the tax software that comes for free
with with the assay and we use that to
look a little bit at what our tumors
actually looked like relative to normal
samples and we also used it to look at
just gene expression overall what genes
were up or down in these tumors relative
to normal tissue and then we also used
our not only to validate those findings
but also to look at how similar and how
different the mouse and human samples
were to one another of tumors so first I
wanted to show you a sample of what the
taksaka actually looks like so this is
just a screenshot of one of my analyses
this is looking at the different human
samples that we had run and this is
simply showing a gene expression of a
handful of genes from this particular
array and all of the different ways that
you can analyze this data so the QC view
and summary of you are really great
because they give you sort of an
overview of the quality of your samples
and all of the different data that you
got back the gene view lets you dive
much deeper into all the p-values the
FDR p-values and figure out which genes
are actually over
expressed or downregulated in each
individual sample and then one of the
other really cool things that this
program or this analysis lets you look
at is the alternative splicing so I'm
not going to talk about that today
because we didn't use it for this
particular question but it's one more
really cool powerful use of this
particular assay so in addition you can
take this gene expression information
and you can plot it in heat maps and
compare your samples and truly see where
the patterns are and you can export that
and use it for figures if you need to
and again one of the great things about
the software that we really appreciated
was that you could measure so many
different things even things that you
might not have thought to ask about so
we were able to look at gene expression
changes which was our major question but
we were also if we wanted able to
evaluate and dig down into splice
variants and non-coding RNAs and that
coverage especially of those lowly
abundant low abundant transcripts was
really helpful for our particular
analysis so one of the main concern I
had and wanted to sort of evaluate
before we went too far was whether or
not the human samples that we had gotten
from the repository looked like
high-grade serous ovarian cancer so high
grade serous is just one of many
subtypes of ovarian cancer and that's
the subtype that this particular id8
model was is supposed to recapitulate so
high-grade serous ovarian cancer in many
patients it's now becoming clear
actually doesn't derive from an ovary
cell it probably derives from a
fallopian tube cell and so one of the
things we wanted to do was principal
component analysis to see if our tumors
looked more like fallopian tube or ovary
now in this example we only had one
normal ovary tissue to look at but you
can see from the principal principal
component analysis that that green
normal ovary sample looks much different
from the red primary ovarian samples and
primary variant tumor samples as well as
different from the metastatic tumor
samples and that the red and purple look
much similar to the blue normal
fallopian tube so that was comforting
because it suggests that what we are
actually seeing is high-grade serous
ovarian cancer so
no the mouse model is derived from an
ovary cell and the human disease is
supposedly in many cases derived from
fallopian tube we wanted to know is it
still able to recapitulate the similar
pathways gene expression path pathways
and the micro environment so when we
looked at our analysis and aligned all
of these pathways side by side we use
the KEGG pathways The Keg database in
order to evaluate pathways that seem to
be relevant or could be relevant or the
efficacy of immunotherapy so here I'm
showing 98 of the pathways that we chose
to analyze that came back is not
statistically different either between
the mouse tumors and primary disease or
between the mouse tumors and the
metastatic human disease so this was
really exciting because most people are
very skeptical about what transplantable
models are actually simulating and so
the fact that these came back looking
incredibly similar to human disease is
really encouraging it suggests that we
might actually be able to use this to
model quite a few of the obstacles that
the human disease presents to
immunotherapy now that said there
definitely were some pathways that were
not the same and most of these came out
as metabolic pathways which isn't
completely surprising we know that this
is a tumor cell line that is grown and
maintained in vitro so tumor cells again
adapt very readily to their environment
and so it's not surprising that these
cells have over expression of lots of
metabolic pathways it just means that
when we truly are evaluating our data
from these mice we'll have to keep that
in mind that the metabolic environment
in these tumors is much harsher than
what we will probably be up against in
patient tumors so going forward we found
all these pathways that were very very
similar and several packets that were
different but ultimately because most of
the pathways that were similar were the
ones that were incredibly relevant or
things like suppressive cells or antigen
processing in presentation we decided
this seemed like a good model to keep
moving forward with in terms of
evaluating whether or not adoptive
t-cell therapy with engineered cell
could prolong survival in these advanced
stage mice so we did go back and try to
validate some of these immunosuppressive
features using immunohistochemistry so
here I'm showing for example staining
for myeloid cells which are very
well-known immunosuppressive cell in
tumor microenvironment
so this is data both from human
high-grade serous samples as well as the
mouse id8 veg a tumor these are tumors
again that were grown in these mice for
at least eight to ten weeks before we
took these samples and we've seen
similar data for regulatory t-cells as
well the suppressive cells are
definitely present in both systems and
we've also seen that both human and
mouse disease overexpress or at least
have abundant expression of the I gather
proposed for some of those inhibitory
receptors that I showed you before are
present on our t-cells when we pull them
out after they've been in tumors for
about 21 plus days so for example
collected 9 has been proposed as one of
the ligand sorts in 3 and collectin 3 is
one of the ligands proposed fine to lag
3 which both send negative signals to
t-cells so armed with this and armed
with some preliminary data that
suggested that a single dose of t-cells
did not prolong survival at all we
decided to go at this really in and hit
it as hard as we could so we made our
t-cells and this time instead of just
injecting one dose we decided well these
t-cells are becoming dysfunctional
fairly quickly so let's give fresh
t-cells Oh often let's give fresh
t-cells every 14 days so that we're
constantly hitting the tumours with
effector T cells that have the potential
to kill them and in addition to just
being t-cells we're gonna give T cells
and boost those T cells in vivo so this
is actually a protocol that was
pioneered in a cancer cell paper by one
of my colleagues and Vince promised in
2015 and so we essentially recapitulated
or our utilized that treatment technique
in these mice to see if it would prolong
survival so again we wait until there's
detectable disease at a late stage and
then we give a limpid depletion regimen
to simulate what often happens in the
clinic
this has also been shown in the
literature to promote self persistence
donor self persistence
so we tried treating with cytoxan to
Limbo to flee prior to treat t-cell
treatment and then and when we give
t-cells this time we give T cells with
peptide post irradiated splenocytes that
way we're giving those T cells a quick
antigen boost in vivo to try to expand
them and increase those numbers in the
animal so we only give the limpo Dupree
lympho depletion regimen once for the
first treatment after that we give fresh
T cells and this vaccine boost every 14
days and we followed the mice to look at
how long they would survive and in this
case I will note that we are giving Isle
to every time we give T cells or 10 days
just to make sure that we're supporting
supporting the survival and
proliferation of those cells in vivo and
we were really excited to see that this
does significantly prolong survival of
the mice when we treat with as you can
see by the red bar on the survival plot
on the screen and what we were really
excited to see was that if we actually
take these tumors out of the mice after
3t cell treatment doses and look for
cleaved caspase-3 in these tumors we see
that it is expressed at much higher
levels in the mice that are treated with
tumor specific T cells then in either
untreated mice or mice that are treated
with an irrelevant T cell so this was
really exciting it suggests that our T
cells are truly making a difference when
we put them in the animals that are
bearing tumors and now our real question
is can we make it better so like I
mentioned earlier in the talk one of the
things we really wanted to do was see if
we could identify obstacles to T cell
efficacy and then figure out a way
around them so the example I'm going to
show you today has to do with altered T
cell trafficking and survival so we
mentioned earlier that the t sliver
putting in weren't persisting and this
could be for a number of reasons but one
of the reasons we found in the
literature that we wanted to explore
further is actually published by George
Kuh kosis group several years ago and
they showed that in high-grade serous
ovarian cancer there's actually this
increased
expression of bass ligand which sends a
death signal to t-cells and it's
expressed at high levels on the tumor
vasculature and they showed that the
mouse idea by Jeff model also over
expresses fast lag in on the tumor
vasculature so this gave us an idea we
thought what if we can somehow take that
fast ligand signal and instead of
manipulating the tumor itself what if we
can engineer the t-cells to see that
death signal but to see the signal in a
different way so I teamed up with a
colleague of mine in the lab dr. Shannon
Oda who's an excellent molecular
molecular biologist and she engineered
this panel of what we're calling
immunomodulators fusion proteins so
there's an ecto domain that is the fast
receptor so this is where the molecule
actually will see or recognize that fast
ligand signal but instead of having the
intracellular domains that would send a
death signal she used it with molecules
that will send a positive signal
something that will either some support
proliferation or survival to try to act
both as a dominant negative so that the
T cells are ignoring or not receiving
that death signal but also to override
it and send even more of a positive
supportive signal to the T cells so
essentially trying to use the tumor
evasion mechanism against itself so we
did several different versions of this
constructs as you can see on the screen
I'm just showing you a couple of
examples we actually tested a really
huge array of these molecules and we
narrowed it down to some that we thought
had the most potential and so here I'm
showing you cd28 and 401 B B which have
actually been talked about in the
literature before as switch signals or
ways that you can send a positive signal
to t-cells and we did a lot of in vitro
experiments to try to identify which of
these had the greatest potential in vivo
and for the sake of time I'm not going
to show you all of those experiments but
I'll tell you that it looked like based
on the preliminary experiments that we
did the fast or when BD constructs
looked much stronger so in terms of
cytokine production and the
proliferation and survival and
transcription factor expression all of
those were consistently better in
fast forward baby cells so we took that
into our mice and tried to add this to
the survival curve see how cells Express
both the mesothelioma dilatory fusion
protein could function in vivo and we
were really excited to see that when we
include one of these fastball and beanie
constructs we actually see even greater
prolonging of survival than if we simply
treat with needs of feelings he sells
alone now one construct worked much
better than the other one didn't seem to
do anything in vivo suggesting that that
molecular biology that you do to make
these constructs really matters quite a
bit but again we were able to overcome
an obstacle that we had identified in
the tumor microenvironment and
essentially figure out a way around it
and make our therapy better because we
made an informed set of experiments
mimicking something that is present in
the mouse model that we know is relevant
for human disease so in conclusion we've
covered a lot of ground today but I
wanted you to walk away knowing that
this idea id8 veg F model actually does
recapitulate many of the key features or
hallmarks of human high grade serous
ovarian cancer including the expression
of a lot of these immunosuppressive
features that are problematic and pose a
lot of limitations or hurdles for
immunotherapy of many kinds and then
also that if you identify an immuno
competent preclinical model that does
characterize or recapitulate features of
human disease
you have this ability to then design
therapeutic strategies that will get
around some of those and those
potentially have increased relevance for
translation in the clinic so with that I
want to thank all of the people that
contributed to this work I have a great
team here at the Fred hutch of
technicians and medical fellows and
undergrads that all work incredibly hard
to get these experiments done I also
want to thank my mentor Phil Greenberg
without whom none of this project just
wouldn't exist shannon oda dr. Shannon
Oda for all of her help
making these fusion proteins because
without her this last Avenue of the
projects wouldn't be what it is and then
again to all of the people who gave us
technologies and samples so that we
could do the really great work that
we're doing and obviously to the funding
sources because without them this work
wouldn't exist either so with that I am
happy to any questions that you have on
what we've done so far
thank you dr. Anderson for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left of your screen well answer
as many of your questions if so you have
time for let's get started our first
question is is the target antigen a self
protein and did you see the toxicity
that's a great question and one that we
do get all the time so thank you very
much for bringing that up
so Musa Phelan is actually a self
protein and that's actually one of the
reasons that we chose to target it is
because an NCI working group selected
this as a really good kid or antigen
simply because it while it is expressed
in some healthy tissues it's actually
expressed in a very very low level and
in many many tumors it's expressed
sometimes ten or a hundreds of times
greater so that actually makes it a good
antigen because the chances of on target
off tumor toxicity are fairly low so
we've been keeping an eye on this
because as you might expect we are
suspicious that targeting a self protein
could cause toxicities or pathologies in
tumor or in excuse me tissues that we
don't want it to and fortunately in all
of the pathology that we have done all
of the basically heme slides that we
have sent all of the pathologists we've
talked to in multiple different
preclinical models we haven't seen any
toxicities so while we have seen
engineered t cells in tissues that have
mesothelioma expressed at normal healthy
levels we haven't seen any pathologies
or any mice that have succumbed to
pathological issues due to t cell
treatment
wonderful thank you our next question
says did Clarion provide you with enough
trim scriptum information for your
project yes actually the Clary MD assay
that we had performed provided us with
above and beyond what we actually needed
for our basic question so we when we got
our data back not only got data on gene
expression but we were also able to get
information on isoforms and splice
variants and things that we are going to
be mining for years to come because we
got so much data out of this one assay
our next question says how was your
experience with tax software for data
analysis how easy was it to learn and
use that's a great question so I am NOT
a bioinformatics expert my training was
in immunology as a graduate student and
then in cancer biology and molecular
biology as a postdoc and so I actually
leaned on thermo Fisher and the tax
software team to learn it the first time
around they were kind enough to send out
a rep to teach me for free how to use
the software to talk me through all of
the logistics and left me with lots of
notes and information that I could
basically teach myself so when I finally
sat down and worked through the software
on my own it was really intuitive and
actually very easy to use so I only
enlisted a bioinformatics expert to make
sure that I had done it right and was
happy to find out that I had so thank
you what kind of combination therapies
are most compatible with engineered T
cell therapy that's a great question and
one that we're still actively
investigating as I showed in the
presentation we think that further
engineering additional components of
cellular petition components of T cells
is very powerful but we think that this
could actually be combined with many
different types of techniques for
example combining this with checkpoint
blockade something that's already in the
clinic has great potential for making
these cells more functional these tumors
along that I currently are
all right we have time for one more
question and this one says why did you
use a service lab to process your
samples
how does sample submission work so
sample submission was very very simple
we contacted the representative and
simply said we have X number of samples
we would like to do this assay and they
sent us a plate everything we needed to
ship them our samples and they did all
the quality testing and that was
actually one of the major reasons that
we wanted to enlist the team to help us
with this no one in my group is an
expert at deep transcriptome profiling
and we wanted to make sure the six are
so valuable and because we had such a
small amount of input that not only were
we not going to make mistakes and lose
valuable sample but also that we had a
thorough QC done to make sure that the
data that we got back was really really
good quality data so we had a great
experience the team was really helpful
easy to communicate with and they were
really fast the turnaround time was
really impressive thank you again dr.
Anderson do you have any final comments
for our audience just thank you so much
for your attendance today and please
feel free to reach out if you have any
further questions before we go I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we do not have time
for today or those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
it would like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through October 2018 lab routes will
alert you via email when it is available
for replay encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye